time
all right and there is representative
gay
and i will following statement
as chair of the house election law
committee i find that due to the state
of emerge
declared by the governor as a result of
the coven 19 payment and in accordance
with the governor's emergency order
number 12
personal to executive order 20204
this public body is authorized to meet
electronic
full committee work session on bills
referred to the house election law
committee
it will be led by an executive station
please note that there is no physical
location
to observe and listen contemporaneously
to this meeting
which was authorized personal to the
governor's agency order
however in accordance with emergency
order i am confirming that we are
a providing public acts to the meeting
by
the phone with additional access
possibilities by video
other electronic means we are utilizing
for this electronic media
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporaneously
during this meeting through this
platform and the public has
access to contemporaneously listen and
if necessary participate in the meeting
by clicking on the following website
address https
colon backslash backslash zoom dot u s
slash j slash 9956391883
or dialing one of the following phone
numbers one
nine two nine two zero five six zero
nine nine
or one three zero one
seven one five eight five nine two
providing public notice of the necessary
information for accessing a meeting
we previously gave notice to the public
of the necessary
information for accessing the meeting
including how to access the meeting
using zoom or
telephonically this information is
printed in the house calendar
subsection c providing a mechanism for
the public to alert the public body
during the meeting if there are problems
with access
if anyone has a problem please call 271
3600 or email at
hcs ledge dot state dot nh dot u
s sub section d adjourning the meeting
if the public is unable to access the
meeting
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting
the meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled please note that all votes
that are taken during this meeting shall
be done by the roll call vote
we will begin by taking role attendance
of the members
when each member states their presence
please also state whether there is
anyone in the room with you
during this meeting which is required
under the right to know
additionally i will say that because of
the extraordinary circumstances
of uh the cobit situation and the fact
that we did not
uh do our normal uh interim study
community process i have indicated
that uh those who wish who were involved
with the bills
may speak for no longer than five
minutes
i think i think that's all and
one more second and i will call up the
first bill
would you like me to call the roll first
the attendant
yes please do so madam clerk
okay chairman cody here
um representative moynihan
excuse me mr chairman um we need to
identify
where you are and if anybody is in the
room with you i am
i am in my residence and no one is in
the house
other than myself okay thanks
representative moynihan yes i'm
here i'm at home and i'm alone
representative porter i'm here
i'm at home in hillsborough my husband
is in the house but not in the room
representative ward uh excuse me i'm at
home at 16 nixon park in portsmouth my
wife's working upstairs and is
liable to barge in at any moment
representative pearson i'm here at 24
franklin street my residence
i'm alone right now but my roommates are
similarly liable to purge in
when they get home thanks okay
representative damaris i am here and my
husband
because his computer is right next to me
might be wandering in and out
i am home in wolfeboro
representative bergeron
is representative bergeron here he's
muted
oh i see him my apologies
i am here i am at my residence in nashua
and there is no one else in the room
with me
representative sandler
i am present i'm in my husband's music
studio in the basement of our home
there's no one in the room with me
representative hamer i am present
i'm in my home in manchester and
i have the dog with me yeah
representative higgins she's absent
okay representative lane
i'm here at my home in concord and i'm
in an office and i am uh alone
in the office my husband is in the in
the home but not here
okay representative martins
i'm in my residence in a room alone in a
house with one other person
representative holzel i'm
home and in raymond
and my husband is in the house but not
in the room thank you
representative gay yes i am here and
catherine is frustrated out of her mind
because she can't get the computer
or the phone to work right now but she's
trying
okay is there anyone else in the home
with you not with me
john's gone shopping okay representative
lang
are we still connected
representative lang is not here okay
he's absent
representative prudhomme o'brien is
trying to get here
representative haywood i am at home
in milton alone in the room but not
alone in the house
representative merlino
not here absent okay
representative owens
she's also not here
representative griffin
hello i'm here i'm alone
and i'm in south carolina oh
sometimes this really helps
just being virtual okay that it's all
committee
members are there any substitutes that
we should be aware of
uh to my knowledge okay
thank you
all right that being the case we will
call up
house bill 541 and i will first went to
a previous arrangement recognize the
sponsor representative ellen reed
thank you mr chair and thank you
honorable members
this bill is on the national popular
vote interstate compact
so i will just speak very briefly as an
overview i know that you've
seen this material before this deals
with the electoral college the electoral
college is
a bit of an anomaly of an election
system
we do not operate any other race any
other election in this country
by this method it was originally a
compromise in the
constitution when different compromises
were being reached in order to pass the
constitution
uh it was a compromise between those who
favored like james madison a direct
election
very similar to how we elect every
single other representative
and those who wanted congress to elect
the president
the result that we have in modern day is
that one out of six when you account for
landslide elections one out of six
of our presidential elections result in
what is called a failed election where
the winner
of the popular vote does not actually
win the office this means actually in
recent years
those those voters who are in their
twenties now
um the three they have experienced three
presidents being elected
two of those presidents that they've
experienced being elected did not win
the popular vote as i said this is the
only race in the country
that is run like this i dare say that we
cannot fathom
for example running the gubernatorial
race like this if you can imagine the
equivalent it would be
separating new hampshire into its 10
respective counties
assigning them a number of electors
according to their
according to their population and then
allowing those electors
by county to be winner take all for
county
in that scenario i think it's clear
because rockingham county has the vast
majority of population that
rockingham county would swing every
almost every
gubernatorial race so back to the
constitution
this is a states rights issue in our
constitution article 2 section 1 it
states and i quote each state shall
appoint in a manner
such as the legislature thereof may
direct a number of electors this means
that we
the state of new hampshire legislature
of the state of new hampshire get to
choose how we allocate
our electors and indeed originally all
of the states
had allocated their electors
proportionally um
i believe it was back in the 1800s i
want to say is nebraska don't hold me to
that
not nebraska i apologize it was another
western state
figured out that if they went to winner
take all instead of proportional
allocation for the electors all of a
sudden the
candidates would spend more time because
their state meant
more and this began a kind of race
amongst the different states
to rush to make their states win or take
all
and now where there are only two states
that are still proportional that is
nebraska in maine
and the result is that we have what we
call battleground states
so in every race approximately five to
states are really the only important
states and we know this
this means that a voter in a safe state
their vote simply does not matter it is
not one person one vote
a republican in california that person's
vote does not matter
a democrat in texas that person's vote
is not does not matter because those
states
are winner take all and they are safe um
this the the safe states the
non-battleground states account
for 70 percent of all the voters which
means 70 percent of voters
are essentially their votes do not
matter as much as voters in
battleground states this violates one
person one vote
now with this compact speaking
specifically about this compact if we
were to sign onto this compact as a
number of other states have already
nothing would change for the time being
uh states
equivalent i think reaching almost 200
electoral votes or
yes electoral votes almost 200 have
signed off already
we need 270 in order for this compact to
go into effect
so nothing would change for the time
being until the extra
approximately 74 i believe electoral
vote equivalent of states
sign off once that happened
once that does happen then we would
simply allocate
our four electors to the winner of the
national popular vote
and what this would do as would be other
states and what this would do is ensure
that whoever won the popular vote
across the country would in fact warning
the electoral
excuse me for four and a half minutes
all right i'm almost done we'd also win
the electoral vote
meaning that the candidate who won by
popular vote would win the presidency
and it would work like every other
election
in our country um so it i just want to
be very clear
that our this would not impact our
primary system it would not impact our
status as first in the nation
and it would not impact our selection
process for for electors
it would simply mean that our status our
voters in our state
their votes would count the same as any
other voter in the country there would
no longer be winning a state as we think
of it one vote in
new hampshire would be the same as a
vote in texas as in idaho as in
tennessee
all votes would be treated equally and
with that i will say that
i'll take questions and i'll defer to
the experts that i have today with me
i have three experts with me who will i
believe are prepared to speak
so are you are you referring questions
to them are you
going to take them i'm happy to take
questions myself
if they're technical in nature and i'm
unable i'm happy to defer to them as
well
are there any questions for
representative reid for members of the
committee
i hear none no no very much
how do you raise your hand
i'm at the bottom of the screen at the
bottom of the participant panel
on the right hand side of your uh screen
there's a raised hand feature
representative gay if you speak up i'll
hear you if you want to ask a question
okay i just wanted to ask if there is
any
other national election besides the
presidential one
um so no this would only impact the
there are federal elections to be clear
this is the the presidential election is
the only one for whom the district
the entire country so it's the only one
for whom
the electoral college is used so this
impacts only the presidential election
it is the presidential elections already
but a bit of a unicorn amongst races
so this is merely making that election
work like every other election in our
country
but we don't have and i'm sorry i'm
sorry for the further question
okay yes so so we don't have
any other election to compare it to
that involves the entire nation
right our the only election in our
country
for whom the enti the district is the
entire country
is the president um we can compare it to
say other countries
as far as i know no other modern
democracy operates this way
um we can compare it to other races like
say for example the executive branch in
any particular state is the governor
no no state operates this way when they
elect a governor
we can even compare it as i said to the
earliest version
of electoral college when each of those
states did proportion out proportionally
and not winner take all in which case
the results
more closely match the national popular
vote
in those days we didn't have very many
field elections it is only in modern
times where we have winner take all in
almost every state where we have what we
call field elections
further questions follow-up
follow-up representative gay one final
follow-up i promise one final
okay uh so so perhaps
this is this is a question so perhaps
you would be happy if it was just
proportional
if the electoral college was
like maine and nebraska that's right
certainly yes yes representative thank
you very much for the question i'm glad
you asked that i didn't want to go into
detail with the timer's constraints but
so that would help us get closer to
mirroring
um what the national popular vote looks
like
it is not perfect because those
proportion proportioning out of the
electoral votes goes by
congressional within each of those
districts is still winner take all
it does not actually count one person
one vote each person's vote being
being regardless of where they are
because it is
according to their district in that
state but it would
be a big step towards making it more
uh reflective of the popular vote you
are correct in that
is senator pearson here
senator pearson i will um allow him to
speak
he is recognized and also mr chairman um
representative pruden o'brien has joined
us she she's
the persevered and and um is here
excellent welcome representative and
maybe she could um
announce her attendance and and if
anybody is in the room with her
please please representative o'brien
tell us that you're here
and whether or not there's anyone in the
room with you i
am uh here i hope you can hear me uh my
dog is with me
and my daughter is upstairs ignoring
this
and my husband may walk in all right
uh the chair recognizes senator pearson
of the great state of vermont
how do you do can everybody hear me and
see me
we can see your picture yes okay all
right
um well if it's all right with you i'll
leave just my picture i i am here
um my connection may not be that good
mr chair i i i would be happy to just
um sit by and see if there are questions
with us today is also pam wilmot from
common cause
right i was going to recognize her next
actually
okay why don't you uh
if you like because i've met with the
committee before
um if if it makes sense for you i'd be
happy to just stick around in case there
are questions
and you can hear from folks you haven't
heard from before and
uh but unless i can always talk about
national popular vote and why i think
it's good for the country
if you like uh i think since we have had
a public hearing on this previously
uh it was some while ago however if if
you're just
uh happy to take questions i will ask
are there any questions for senator
pearson
from members of the committee
speak up please i may be on a different
screen at any given moment
and no indications are being made okay
uh thank you senator uh in that case i
recognize pam walmart
of common cause
and just take me a second to
find her all right she is here
miss wilmot you're recognized oh thank
you
uh mr chairman uh members of the
committee my name is pam wilmott
i am vice president of state operations
at
uh common cause which is a national
nonprofit with state chapters across
the state of the country unfortunately
although we have
6 000 members in new hampshire
we don't actually have an office there
but i'm a frequent
a hiker and love new hampshire and hope
to
be moving there sometime soon so um
anyway uh national popular vote is
a priority for common cause along with
many other democracy and good government
organizations organizations like the
league of women voters
the american civil liberties union
[Music]
deimos fair vote public citizen
many other local conservation
groups and a whole list i think we're
pretty close to including national and
state organizations about 100
different ones and that's because
the way we elect the president is in
fact unique
and is been broken for a very long time
it's the only election where votes
are not equal throughout the district
a vote in a battleground state is
worth more than a spectator state and we
believe that every vote should be equal
in every election because these things
shift over time
i know that you know new hampshire is
very important for having the first
primary in the nation and as a small
state
having that role is very important with
retail politics that
is not the same thing in the general
election
and our country is
founded on that very principle the
electoral college was in fact
a compromise senator haines is going to
probably speak a little bit later he can
probably talk
more about that and in fact
we've elected a president and changed
the way we've done electors in this
country many
many different times represented
mentioned proportional allocation
that is not currently used it's actually
a bad
idea as is the district method
of selecting electors which we have two
states maine and nebraska
because none of them embrace the
principle of one person one vote
and none of them assure that the
candidate with the most
votes wins and none of the other
two systems or three mean that
every vote and every election and every
state
is important so we believe in
citizen participation and citizen
participation in elections
and i think there's nothing that you
could do or we could do as a country
that would
fix that as well as add to the security
of our election system and
implementing a national popular vote um
we have i think as as the representative
mentioned
uh we are 15 states in the district of
columbia with 196 electoral votes
maine and vermont i'm sorry
vermont and massachusetts connecticut
rhode island are all states that have
passed it
and we hope that uh we'll
get many many more in the years to come
uh this is a system that the public
knows is broken
that they want to change they've wanted
change for a long time
and this gives us an opportunity to do
that in a constitutional and effective
way
so i think i'll stop there and uh i know
you're very busy and these remote
hearings are a little tricky so
thank you for allowing me to testify
thank you miss wilmotter are there any
questions from ms wilmot from members of
the committee
hearing none thank you very much thank
you and
let's see is senator haynes available
from the state of california
former senator haynes i'm here
if you can hear me yep you're recognized
great thank you mr chairman uh members
of uh committee miss
uh smartling and the and the rest of the
staff i appreciate the opportunity to
talk to you
i'm gonna come at this a little bit
differently than uh both senator pearson
and ms wilmot did
i want to come at the concept of the
national popular interstate compact
from a conservative perspective a little
little bit of my background
i was in the california legislature for
14 years i was the senate republican
whip
i was the chairman of the american
legislative exchange council
in the year 2000 i was also the chairman
of the senate constitutional amendments
committee
in california i first got involved in
electoral college reform
as a result of my experience in the
george w
bush campaign i was one of the first 25
elected officials in the country in
february of 1999
to endorse then governor bush for
president
only to find after he looked me in the
face and said he was going to campaign
in california in 2000 to find out in
september of 2000
they had walked away from the state that
started getting me looking at
electoral college reform my first effort
was looking at a congressional district
system that's a system in effect
in maine and in nebraska i walked away
from that because i didn't think that
would solve what i
what i call the major problem of winner
take all laws it is important to
understand
that the national popular vote
interstate compact does not eliminate
the
the electoral college in fact it uses
the language of article two section one
to allow the state uh to in it as an
exercise in federalism for the state to
make the determination
of what's in the state's best interest
and the challenge i came to it as a
conservative is i believe
neither party most conservatives in this
country live in what i call the big l
which is the mountain and midwest states
and the south
um and in those states
neither party addresses the concerns of
conservatives because they are in
safe most of them are in safe republican
states and or
in safe democrat states and their vote
don't matter it doesn't matter as in my
case i'm a republican in california the
least
relevant uh voter in the country is a
republican in california
and so i wanted to do something to get
conservative values
and uh get parties talking about
conservative values and addressing
conservative concerns literally the
problem is not the electoral college in
fact preserving the electoral college is
an important thing
because right now article 1 section 4 of
the constitution
puts election law in the hands of
the state legislatures if you ever
eliminated the electoral college you'd
knock defenses off of article 1 section
which has been very very narrowly
interpreted by the supreme court
and congress could then step in and
start writing election law and i tell my
democrat friends that you don't want
republicans writing election law because
they would write the law to say you need
three forms of id
and a concealed carry permit before you
to be allowed to vote
uh by republican friends i say you don't
want democrats doing that because they
would right
say as long as you can still read
somebody's name on their uh
on their headstone they'd be allowed to
vote so bottom line on the thing is you
want to keep election law in the hands
of
the state legislatures and preserving
the electoral college
is worth that interestingly enough the
winner-take-all law that is in effect in
48 of the 50 states
was actually opposed by james madison if
you take a look at the constitutional
convention
they took 30 votes over 22 days on how
to elect the president united states and
they couldn't reach an agreement
when it was all said and done this was
the compromise they came up with
but of those 30 votes in those 22 days
none of them was the winner take all law
one of them was legislative appointments
which six or seven states had after
uh it was turned down in the uh
constitutional convention
and then enacted in states others had
governor appointments
others had electoral college districts
as opposed to congressional districts
all of these things were voted on but
turned down in the constitutional
convention
pardon me four and a half minute warning
okay thank you
anyhow just kind of let you know i
believe there are good solid
conservative reasons uh to vote or to to
to allow the vote in all uh 50 states
make every single voter in every single
state
important in every single election i
think it's good for the conservative
movement and i think that's what's good
for the country
thank you senator are there any
questions for the senator from members
of the committee
hearing none thank you very much sir
thank you
is there anyone else who will speak on
house bill 541 that's the
final indication i've had that anybody
wishes to speak
anyone else who's here
thank you i will close the hearing on
the word session aspect on hb
541 i'm sorry mr chairman i'm
sean parnell raised his hand in the
audience the attendee
uh you you may recognize mr parnell i i
would i would reiterate that he will
have five minutes as all other speakers
will have
all right oops i'm sorry
just a sec i i was trying to lower his
hand and i um
unfortunately cut off his speaking
ability now
all right are we okay i'm on we're good
thank you and i will keep this brief um
i spoke
uh last year at uh committee hearing on
this so i think a lot of you
may be familiar with some of the things
that i've said in the past so i'll just
sort of
reiterate a few of those and maybe talk
about a few other things that have been
raised
one of the biggest problems with
national popular vote is just
that it relies on the cooperation of
non-member states
in order to obtain the necessary vote
totals the reality is there is
no actual official national popular vote
count
uh what npv tries to do is sort of
cobble together vote counts
from some states that are going to be
fully willing and other states that
might be a little bit resistant
and because each state is in charge of
its own processes and timelines
uh there are is a substantial likelihood
of there being problems in terms of
obtaining vote counts
from other states and it may not be
states being obstinate
it may be uh just a state has had some
sort of a
natural disaster like what happened with
new york in 2012
when they submitted something called
their certificate of ascertainment which
is
i'm going to say a source of vote totals
that npv
has identified as being a source that
can be used
to sort of skip over a larger dispute on
this topic
for the moment but anyways that
certificate was missing about 415
000 votes under national popular vote
the vote totals on that certificate
still would have had to have been used
uh we're coming into our first covid
election of course
i think that the chance and likelihood
of there being
significant delays in states being able
to report their full
and accurate vote counts is there's a
pretty high chance that there's going to
be problems with that
and under npv any problem in any other
state
is going to have significant uh impact
um real quickly just getting back to a
couple of things that i've heard
um actually the very first presidential
election we did have some states
under the winner take all system
maryland and pennsylvania
that's actually in the book published by
national popular vote as well as other
sources of course
and the the statement that you wouldn't
elect your governor this way
that's true and the reason is because
new hampshire is not a federation
composed of its counties your counties
are
subdivisions of the state of new
hampshire
whereas the united states of america is
in fact a federation of states they are
independent sovereign nations that have
joined into a federation
and when you have federations whether
they're political federations
or you know civic federations this is
actually fairly typical for what you
find
in fact very few nations actually elect
their chief executive
by direct elections most of them have
some sort of a two-step
process usually in a parliamentary form
uh and and so there while this is unique
in the united states of america to have
an electoral college on the national
scene
you know ours looks a little bit
different than germany's and germany
looks a little bit different
than the united kingdom's and all these
other nations but
this is a fairly common type of setup
and in fact many nations democratic
nations
in recent decades have in fact had the
second
place party or party coalition
have their leader become the prime
minister
of their nation so we're not quite the
outlier that maybe
has been suggested and finally i'll just
go and conclude with this
national popular vote i don't think is
actually a solution to the winner take
all
problem winner take all was adopted for
a variety of reasons
it has its pluses it has its minuses but
there are
alternatives that new hampshire or any
other state can adopt
that not only would reflect the will of
the voters of new hampshire
in some way shape or form but perhaps
just as importantly
it does not require any state to wait
around for
years or possibly decades or maybe even
never
for it to go into effect if winner take
all is
in fact the problem that you wish to
address
then there are alternatives like the
congressional district system
uh some sort of proportional system or a
threshold
system and i'd be happy to talk about
any of those i'm not necessarily
advocating for any of those they like
anything else have their pluses and have
their minuses
but there's no reason for you to wait to
solve
what you might think of as the winner
take all problem
you have that within your power you know
maybe not right now headed into the 2020
election
but certainly before 2024 you can solve
this
if you want to without having to wait
for other states
to come on to this compact as well so
i'm happy to take questions at this
point
is there any questions for the gentleman
from members of the committee
hearing none thank you very much you're
very welcome and i will close
the section of these mr chairman i hate
to interrupt
but uh mr senator pearson from vermont
has his hand up in the attendees
all right senator pearson what did you
have
you indicated you didn't want to speak
any further but go ahead
wait just a sec i need to um
uh find him again oh his hand is down
actually
okay did did you have it what's up
i'm sorry there we go hi i i just
i i really have to comment that it is
complete fiction that there's no such
thing as a count
mr parnell has asserted this over and
over but he ignores that
every state's result is a public result
in fact they're public at the precinct
level there's no mystery
and the idea that uh something like new
york
i'm not going to get into you know a
call of duty
um at this point so um
just a factual factual mistake that i
wanted to correct but thank you
uh thank you is there anyone further who
wishes to speak on
house bill 541 hearing none
we will move next to
the next bill on the list which is
house bill 554 is there anyone who
wishes to speak
on house bill 554
i i see representative bergeron has his
hand up
representative you're recognized uh just
a question of the chair
uh were we going to execute these bills
uh after
testimony on each one or are we
we were going to do that until i read in
the statement i read
uh to you a few minutes ago that it said
no an executive session will follow the
work session
i interpret that as meaning we have to
take them up all at the end
thank you i didn't listen to all of your
uh opening remarks
it does say that and that's when i
decided we were going to do everything
at the end
so that that be i should have probably
made that clear representative bergeron
thank you
uh we will move therefore to house bill
554.
is there anyone who wishes to speak on
house bill 554
thank you i would also say that there
were some there's at least one member of
the committee
two members of the committee who weren't
here for the hearings on
uh these bills and so that was one
reason i decided to give people a little
leeway
no one should assume that future work
sessions of the
committee at least while i am chair are
necessarily going to involve
uh this stability and there's also the
rather unusual circumstances in which we
find ourselves
uh we will move then to um
house bill 728 and i do have indication
that there are
people wishing to speak on that and i
will recognize representative ellen reed
representative reed thank you can you
hear me
yes i can hear all of you i can hear all
the committee members
okay i am i'm not a committee member but
i do appreciate
um the time to present before you mr
chair and all of the committee members
um so again this is something that
you've seen a few times i will give you
a brief overview i have a number of
experts
who are willing to go in more detail on
some of the issues that the committee
has raised
before and and has expressed they would
like more information about
so i think i've mentioned as i've been
before you many times i teach american
government and when i teach american
government to my students
i talk about the evolution of democracy
in fact our founding fathers
uh felt very very strongly that
democracy was going to be the end
ultimate result of every um political
system
because that was the tendency of the
human nature
to go towards uh not not democracy
uh any kind democracy but specifically
representative democracy what we refer
to as a republic
and when we have a republic a
representative democracy it requires
elections now at the time the election
system that our founders gave us
known as first past the post was
relatively new and progressive and um
maybe even radical in some senses but it
was the best that they had it was the
most
democratic method they had of of um
tallying
the will of the electorate the problem
with
first past the post is something that
the founders actually
um in writing and federalist essays
warned against which is
that it leads to factions madison wrote
extensively as did other founders
about the evils of factions we call it
today parties
but they really did not want us to have
um parts at all but
especially a two-party system which
first passed the post
actually lends us towards most people in
fact hate
the fact that we have a two-party system
in effect because they see the divisive
negative polarization that um that
has become of our country because of the
polarization
two parties and the fact that in an
election
um people are not free to simply vote
their conscience or vote for the person
they think that has
the best ideas they are essentially
forced into one of the two parties
because any other vote for any
independent or third party candidate
is seen as a throwaway vote in fact
one third of all voters or over a third
of voters consider themselves
independents
or third party but again they are not
free
to um to vote for who they want because
they have to engage in this kind of
strategic voting because of this spoiler
effect
if they throw away their vote on a third
party candidate it gives
the person they really don't want an
advantage
so this has led to negative campaigning
this kind of fear mongering between oh
you have to vote for my person even if
that person isn't
your preference because we're afraid of
the other party
it's also led because of all this
negativity and polarization
and the fact that people can't really
vote their conscience it's led to a lot
of voter apathy and
decreased turnout um so this is exactly
the opposite of what our founders
wanted for our country so the system
ranked choice voting
um actually solves all of those problems
that i just laid out
it solves the spoiler effect and
strategic voting
because it gives more choices it because
it offers more
level playing field to all of the
candidates it allows every single vote
to count
equally it produces
the highest resolution picture of what
the electorate actually wants and it
finds the candidate that has the most
overall absolute support
and because of all this it decreases
negative campaigning everywhere that
it's
been instituted and it depolarizes
politics and it also promotes voter
turnout and engagement
because people feel because they know
they feel like their vote actually
matters
so really briefly i'm going to go over
how it works in general again i have
experts that will go
more into details but as a voter it's
highly highly intuitive and simple
you get a ballot where instead of just
choosing one you actually rank your
preferences we can all do this when it
comes to maybe our favorite flavor of
ice cream
i can say vanilla then followed by
cookie dough then
chocolate for example and
in what we call single member districts
this is the majority of races where you
have
one winner any race where you have one
winner it works exactly like
a runoff election only it happens
instantly
so you're probably already familiar with
runoff elections but just as an actual
example this is how
us the we the state house elects
a speaker of the house so when we
when we have uh more than uh two
candidates
the candidate with the lowest number of
votes uh gets eliminated and we all vote
again
from the remaining options so that's
exactly what this is
only uh it happens instantly because
those uh
further elections runoff election result
their run-off election choices are
actually already recorded on that first
ballot
so all of those runoff elections can be
done without a new election being called
um so uh the major questions that i've
heard from the committee before
is how is this going to be done with
multi-member districts in fact
multimedia districts where we have
multiple winners like new hampshire
state house
districts it is actually a boon um
your time is up thank you very much are
there any questions for representative
reid from members of the committee
let's see representative porter's hand
is up representative porter you're
recognized for a question
thank you mr chair and i admit that i'm
one of the committee members who wasn't
here for the hearing on this although
i have heard it in the past the question
that i have
is um in a phone call that a
committee a constituent made to me i was
assured that the
the machines that we have currently in
hillsborough
could be used to count these um
these ballots is that actually a fact or
will there be a need for special
equipment to count
and if so where does that money come
from to buy those special equipment
thank you very much for the question i'm
so happy that you asked it
so this is the overall implementation
issue that i did want to address
the fact of the matter is the secretary
of state's office is looking into
purchasing new
machines for the entire state and in
fact
of all the machines that they are
looking at all of them are ranked choice
voting ready incompatible or rather
they're all compatible
the one that seems to be the favorite of
the office is the dominion
model and that one is actually
specifically ranked choice voting
ready so it is absolutely designed but
they all are compatible they all
put out a file known as a cvr
that actually is makes it easy to
tabulate with open source software
i will say that so on the town level
nothing would change
the clerks and the moderators would all
do everything exactly the same there's
no additional work for the towns
the only thing that would have to happen
is in towns with
these machines they would have couriers
take the memory cards because we do not
want machines hooked up to the internet
so they take the memory cards to a
central location in towns with
hand counts they take they courier the
ballots to a centralized location all
this is done by the secretary of state
and that is that centralized location
that under the security stick
is where um all of this would be
tabulated with open source software is
free is completely transparent
um and maine has already done this so in
maine i think
because the secretary of state maine
dunlap wanted to
kind of be conservative about the cost
he estimated that the cost of going over
to ranked choice voting would be around
a little north of 1 million in fact when
they implemented it again that major
part of that cost was the querying of
the ballots and the memory cards uh it
ended up being a little
i think it was just a teeny bit over a
hundred thousand dollars and they were
able to do it in three months
so i do have another expert who can talk
more at length about the experience in
maine
but i wanted to answer your question and
talk about implementation
there i have a follow-up mr chair
follow-up representative porter
certainly thank you
so if i understood right and i might not
have
we would not have the results the night
of the election then the
the cards would go someplace else to be
tabulated
so as i understand it the the most
of a delay that would exist would be
from
the delay that would exist the machine
the the high speed
scanner which would be rented for very
low cost a few thousand dollars
in maine rinse these as well those are
only for the hand count towns
the rest are just memory cards and all
of the computation is done relatively
instantly so the really the only delay
is in the time it takes to courier the
ballads or memory cards from the various
towns so if you take the furthest town
away from concord
and do the courier time you're looking
at a delay of several hours
not days um and indeed a lot of races
still to this day
right now do not get certified because
they're either too close or what or what
have you
um that night but in general we would
have results that night it would might
be a few hour delay and we can look to
maine
and their results to kind of confirm
this thank you
is ms tiana coleman available thank you
representative reed
thank you representing new hampshire
independent voters
she is i will um find her in the list
and got her hand up there you go
okay can you hear me all right
absolutely i can
great thank you for having me
um i just wanted to talk a little bit
about how ranked choice voting is very
widely accepted and used
both as a nonpartisan reform measure and
as legally accepted as well so first of
all i just wanted to say that it's
been tried and tested in many places
it's used statewide
in maine now as you know for their
federal elections and for all of their
primary elections
it's both state and federal it's also
used in local elections in 11 states in
the country
um it's used in many of the major cities
it's used for military and overseas bell
it's an additional six
states it's been used in the 2020
presidential primaries in four states
and it's gaining widespread support
with various ballot measures across the
country
the most prominent one being
massachusetts which will be on their
november 2020 ballot
as a ballot measure there are 500
organizations and several counties that
also use it with a lot of success so
um it's something that's gaining a lot
of
respect and it's kind of a reform for
our time so i think it's something that
you should definitely consider
it's also a non-partisan reform it
really does not benefit
a certain ideology or certain party if
you remember right i have been
a republican chair in the county before
i am now an independent
and i work with a lot of democrats and
this is definitely
a reform that should be
widely accepted by republicans democrats
independents
third parties everyone it simply helps
the people
it simply helps the people who have the
most
support so in our democratic republic
we should want our representatives to be
picked by a majority of their
constituency and not by a small minority
and that's exactly what rank choice
voting does
um in multi-member districts it would be
a majority of seats
that would go to the constituents with
the majority in a minority of seats
would go to those who have a minority
voice
in areas where it's mostly republican it
would help them in areas where it's
mostly democrat it would probably help
them if there's an area that's mostly
independent it would probably help them
so it's not really meant to help any
particular
constituency and what it does is it
protects the voice of the majority
without trampling on the voice of the
minority it gives both
those in the majority and in the
minority more voice and more choice
um it helps us so that our winners are
not a fluke
due to vote splitting but that they are
actually represent
who the voters truly want um
next we just wanted to go over the
constitutionality of rank choice voting
um in maine there was a constitutional
challenge and it's been challenged in
other states as well
and every time it's been found
constitutional by the u.s constitution
the first circuit court of appeals
rejected an appeal
of their district court's um
case that declared that it was perfectly
constitutional meaning that
the first circuit agreed that it's that
it's constitutional
they said that nothing in the nothing in
the us constitution would
say that ranked choice voting violates
the voting rights act
nothing would say that it nothing would
require a first pass
the post requirement um it nothing
violates the equal protection clause
and nothing violates the one-person
one-vote
concept so it's it's as far as the u.s
constitution goes
it's completely constitutional in fact i
would note that there was a case
uh in michigan where the justice
department brought
a voting rights lawsuit against
them because they were using an at-large
election and it was discriminatory
against
black people and not having as much of a
voice and they actually
settled the case by promising to
institute ranked choice voting
because then that would be more fair so
ranked choice voting is actually
a better reform makes things better um
some of you may have asked about the
plurality provision in new hampshire's
constitution
um it is similar to maine's plurality
provision
and um a few things you need to know
about that is that
what the main supreme court decided was
only
a a it was non-binding precedent
it would it is not relevant to any of
our federal elections
so we only have a plurality provision
four and a half minute morning
okay it's only relevant to state
elections for governor and for
executive council state senate state
house
and so you could still do federal
elections without any problem not to
mention that it's not a binding
precedent
it would need to still be adjudicated on
the merits and
in many cases plurality is interpreted
as most votes cast
which would make it completely apply
because ranked choice voting
can be a method of arriving at a
plurality winner
the time is up man thank you
are there any questions for ms coleman
from members of the committee
hearing none pam do you have any
indication of any
questions from this committee
thank you
and is mr feign available mr howie fane
i don't think i can hear you okay is
that good now
yes mr fan you are recognized okay good
afternoon uh
chair cody and the committee um my name
is howard fain i will be addressing
ranked choice voting in the context of
new hampshire's multi-member districts
i also want to say there was a bit in
this um technical world of
of a snafu and and the slides that were
going to accompany these comments aren't
in front of you
so i'll briefly describe them in some
key circumstances
so um new hampshire not only has the
largest state legislative chamber in the
country
the number and size of its multi-member
districts dwarfed those in the nine
other states that have any at all
and the slide would have reminded
everyone that we have 99
um a multi-member districts totaling 295
just shy of three-fourths of the seats
in the
um house of representatives chamber
and then this unique configuration of
representatives provides a unique
opportunity through the use of
multi-winner ranked choice voting
to allow most new hampshire voters to
elect a representative of their choice
wherever they happen to live and the
chart that would have been on the screen
refers to the 106 um
two member representatives from 53 two
member
districts uh the various configurations
and including there's a six
a seven and eight nine ten and eleven
seat
um uh uh
multi-member districts and so that
figures into the the stats we're going
to look at about how this plays out
so the next thing was fair vote um their
page is called rcv 101
on their site and of course they're the
national clearinghouse on all things rcv
i want to quote what they say about the
multi-member when used to elect more
than one candidate like city council
state legislatures or even congress rcv
is a form of fair representation voting
which more accurately represents the
full spectrum of voters
this is also called sometimes
proportional rcv
it means a party that wins the majority
of votes wins the majority of seats
now that has not always been the case
under the current block voting method
used in the multi-member districts
and then the distortions between votes
one and seats one
within these multi-member districts has
contributed
its share to large-scale majority flips
in the house
based only on modest shifts in votes and
the chart that would have been there is
just the most two recent flips
where about three and a half percent of
change in votes
has resulted in 15 percent
change in seats and this has a
significant effect in polarization and
and it disrupts long-term policy-making
objectives
so um and the next slide would have been
um
about the new hampshire's uh lowest in
the country representation ratio one to
thirty three hundred
the other side of the charts has has
states with up to over 100 000 per
resident
in representation yet this opportunity
presented
by electing multiple representatives at
once and that is an opportunity
for diverse representation of interest
is turned on its head by the incidence
of one-party sweeps
caused by the current block voting
system so a sweep for one party bits
remember is a shutout for the other
and that's before considering voters who
would prefer to be represented by minor
party
or independent candidates if they could
be so when you apply several metrics to
the new hampshire representative results
it's clear that the mmds the
multi-member districts show
just as much evidence of partisan
ticketing voting as
all the other state and federal
elections in the state which is to say a
great deal
since the re-force of the votes to cease
the the three-fourths of the votes to
seats distortion
is comes from mmds three-fourths of the
solution
for each 3 300 new hampshire residents
can come directly from adopting
proportional
rcv as part of this ranked choice voting
package
in the next slide i would have shown you
that one-party sweeps are increasing
in just the last four elections under
this current districting plan
uh it's increasing from 63.4
of all um multi-member districts our
sweeps
then in the um low 70s in the next two
and up to 79.8 percent in 2018.
so when you look at these in the
republican democratic shares you'd see
that in democratic years
the democrats have more sweeps in the
republican years they're more
republicans
but both mean that ever increasing
numbers of voters are unable to elect a
representative of their choice
just because of where they live so even
from competing lawn signs on the same
block
we know that republicans live and vote
in democratic districts and we know that
democrats live and vote in republican
districts
there are districts that have flipped
from one party sweeping in one election
to the other sweeping in the very next
one a hunt fully 111 seats in 38
multi-member districts have experienced
four consecutive one-party sweeps under
this district and plan
since 2012 by the way four and a half
minute warning sir
yes thank you and so proportional rcb
for multi-member districts
will mean that the people of new
hampshire will always be able to you
know look behind the purpleness
and find out who wants you know who
people really want and proportionally
allocate them within these multi-memory
districts
they're like with the single members
there's no spoilers
um and people vote their true
preferences but i'll also add
even gerrymandering disappears in the
multi-member districts you could keep
the exact same
uh map and although you won't because
the census
population shifts will occur but
everyone would get their fair share and
everyone would get a fair deal even
under this current map
and it's just good to know that there's
a you have a unique opportunity in the
nation
using ranked choice voting to address
fair representation
within the multi-member districts thank
you very much for your time
thank you mr friend are there any
questions from members of the committee
for mr fame
i see miss representative griffin has
her hand up representative griffin
you're recognized thank you mr chair
thank you for taking my question
so are you saying that a simple
numerical vote tally is not
an effective representation of people's
wills
i would i am saying that block voting
when um everyone gets as many votes as
there are
seats is an ineffective method of
representation
i would think that if you have a um 55
for a group of one a party of candidates
from one party and 45 percent in fairly
partisan ticket voting
um from another party um and and and one
party sweeps
with that amount uh all the seats eight
seats 11 seats four seats
five seats yes um i am saying that the
method of block voting
in the multi-member districts is not an
effective means of representing all of
the people within that district and
ranked choice voting
proportional ranked choice voting can
resolve that
did you have a follow-up representative
griffin
apparently no thank you mr chair in f
follow up so are you presuming
that people are you presuming the vote
of a person by virtue of the result
because it would seem to me your
conclusion and your reference to block
voting would require an
assumption that in fact everyone is
voting as you
say it um and while there might have
been
some i'm just pointing out that from a
historical perspective because you
looked at some prior elections
there did used to be um
the practice in this state of being able
to simply check a block off to vote for
everybody in a particular party perhaps
contributing to the sweep that you refer
to
um that ability no longer exists
i act i'm sorry um are you finished i
apologize
yes representative griffin yes i keep
trying to
mute myself so i don't have any
background noise and it makes it harder
i'm sorry
okay mr faint yes i'm sorry if i jumped
in too soon um
yes i have been quantifying all the data
from these four elections under the
district plan
quantifying the bloc voting even without
that option for
for for straight ticket voting and you
can compare it
to the um comparison election in
governor especially which happens every
two years
you can compare it um through the
average of the votes
based on the number of candidates you
compare it to the two highest there are
very many
there are several metrics that we are
developing to document
that the existence of partisan voting is
extremely strong
how much variance there is within the
slate of candidates within a given party
we are waiting for the 2020 election
results
um coming up in a couple of months to
add to this database
and we'll produce a report
um explaining how we can
identify that partisan black voting
nature and i will call it
significant and we will make all those
uh all that data available as soon as we
add 2020 in
and i hope that answers your question
that it's it's it's
an objectively you know objective
metrics to try
and get at that question about block
voting
any further questions from members of
the committee for mr feign
representative porter has her hand up
representative porter is recognized
thank you mr chair um thank you mr fang
so i'm trying to get my head around this
i know that we have
a district in um
in the house that is containing two
towns a smaller town
and a larger town and there are a large
number of
um representatives from that district i
think it's 9 or 11 or something like
that
and i know that one of the town the
smaller town has come to us several
times
to ask us to do something about that
because they feel they're
they are saying they don't feel they're
being represented
so my question is i'm thinking of this
especially let's just say that there are
two parties the banana party and the
apple party
and when they the apple party has more
members in this district and so when
the vote comes around um all 11
representatives are
elected by the apple party which has
55 percent of the population are apples
45 percent of the populations are
bananas and they don't get anybody
and what you're saying with this is the
bananas would have a chance
is that right that is exactly right and
if you were talking about the
two towns that make up hillsborough 37
which is 11 but you mentioned nine that
uh so right any of these larger ones or
any of these three
seat ones the idea you're absolutely
right um
now they become competitive the issue in
is whether it's going to be 7-4 or
whether it's going to be 6-5
that's the competitiveness or whether a
flip on the 6-5
um absolutely you have it perfect those
55 45s
become competitive a three district a
three-member district
is almost certainly going to be two to
one in favor of the majority party
but with being heard from the minority
party um
and that's how it works the apples and
bananas and anyone else
in the mix um gets a fair proportional
share
based on the size of the district and
how many seats can be allocated
so six five seven four in that
significant you know that like 56
percent district if you're talking about
the one i am with the two towns
um that i might be thinking you're
talking about um
if it's 56 in favor of that party
um 57 then the battle is on for how to
get the
five six the six five the seven four or
whatever and and
all out push for eight three if you feel
you have the strength you know
but it's the voters that will break it
down to exactly those numbers you
described
thank you thank you sir
uh pam uh is ms luther of the
representing main league of women voters
available
she is and she is right here
ready to speak ms luther you are
recognized
thank you chairman cody and um members
of the committee can you hear me okay
i can yes all right great so um
i've been working on ranked choice
voting in maine for
for quite a few years and i was asked to
comment on
how it worked logistically in the 2018
elections on how difficult it was
for the towns to implement ranked choice
voting
in in maine not sure about how you're
set up in new hampshire but in maine we
have
over 500 individual election
jurisdictions
each one runs their own election each
one has their own town clerk and maine
the town clerk
does the job of the moderator in new
hampshire
so it's a widely dispersed function
some of the bigger towns have much more
professional management some of
the smaller towns have more part-time
management
a lot of diversity in the way elections
are conducted in maine
over 90 percent of our ballots are cast
using optical scanning equipment
we happen to use the esn s d s 200
which is not the same as dominion but is
also
rankers voting compatible our secretary
of state did a long-term lease
on standard voting equipment a few years
ago so all of our towns that do
have scanners use the same equipment um
about half our towns count hand count
ballots
but it's not that many ballots it's you
know less than ten percent of the actual
ballots are hand counted
as repres as representative reed
mentioned earlier you can't
do a statewide rank choice voting tally
unless you bring all of the records
together in a central location so
in maine the towns didn't actually have
any other work to do
they processed on election night just
like they normally would
if they were scanner towns they ran
through the scanner tallies and they
announced
that first choice the first choice votes
cast in the rank choice voting races if
they were hand countdowns
they didn't process all the ranked
choice elements they
tabulated only the first choice votes
and announced those to the press just as
they would on any other election night
the next day wednesday they packaged up
their election materials
signed off on their results did their
balance sheets to make sure they had
accounted for
all the ballots and then those were
couriered to
augusta where as representative reed
described we had
leased a high speed scanner and the
ballots that had been hand counted were
all sped through that
scanner so that we could produce an
electronic
cast vote record which is basically a
record of
the voter preferences on every single
ballot and every single race
once you've got that the tabulation of
the rank choice outcome
takes only a matter of minutes um 20
minutes
or or less actually so it was not really
much work for the te
m much more work for the towns at all
the state did deploy a team of you know
12 or 15 people
that worked on the central tabulation
and there were some expenses to the
state as representative reed
pointed out it was nowhere near as
expensive as we
feared or thought but there were those
expensive
expenses and there was some planning at
the state level but for the towns
it was no more work my town clerk in
ellsworth here
you know she just said it was no
different than running a normal election
the town clerks did get questions about
how rank choice
voting worked and the secretary of state
did a big public relations
push to make sure that voters were well
informed and that clerks had the tools
they need to explain to voters
how to cast a rank choice ballot
one clerk that i know of had a looping
video of the secretary of state giving
his rank choice voting speech that ran
all day on election day so that people
who wanted to be better informed could
watch that video and hear from the
secretary of state how it worked
but our surveys show that exit survey
showed that almost everybody understood
what they were supposed to do
and people didn't really have a problem
or were not
that confused about casting a ranked
choice ballot but anyway the
uh i think i was asked here four and a
half minutes
i think i was asked here to talk about
that that it wasn't really much
different for the towns than
conducting a straight vote for one
election and um
i think i've made that point so if you
have any questions i'm happy to answer
them
are there any questions from ms luther
from members of the committee
i hear none pam do you see any
indications
no all right thank you very much is
there anyone else who wishes to testify
on this bill at this time
i see no humans all right in that case
we will move on to the next bill
which is i believe
house bill 1191 is there anyone who
wishes to speak to
house bill 1191
no hands have been raised going once
going twice
thank you in that event we will move on
to
house build 1390 is there anyone who
wishes to speak to house bill 1390 at
this time
i've got questions i can't really speak
to support it or
and maybe there'll be somebody available
to answer them or maybe they won't be
but
i can't do anything about it um
thank you let's see uh so there's no
indication of anyone wishing to speak on
houseboat 1390 correct
that's correct okay in that event um
representative pruden o'brien did you
want to take an opportunity
to speak to uh house bill 1457
well um yeah i mean i would say the same
thing that i said before
bless you okay so there we go i just
said
we all know what i said before i don't
want to belabor it
uh so all of that stands the only thing
i have to add
is that
this should be made um a recommendation
instead of uh so that
um
it's too difficult for many
um clerks
in the larger towns and supervisors of
the checklist to manage
at this point so if it's a
recommendation
you can continue to think about how to
implement that
in the future um i still believe it's
it's it's valuable
and something to continue to work
towards but
in the larger cities it's it was shouted
you would you would concede that there
are significant difficulties with the
current
form of the bill under under present
circumstances
that that a fair statement that's what
we were told and i don't want to
i don't want to coerce um people to
into doing things that are very
difficult for them to do i know the town
clerks already have a lot of work
and supervisors of the checklist
so i would like to just continue to look
for ways to make it more manageable for
them
well i was going to suggest you you you
are aware of course representative that
you're at liberty to refile some form of
this
bill in the future yes so that's
so that is what i would like to do all
right thank you very much
and given that is there anyone else who
wishes to
speak to house bill 1457
i would assume not no hands are up
all right we will move to house bill
1668 and i will ask the same question is
there anyone who wishes to speak to it
okay in that case we will commence with
the previously scheduled executive
session
it is not the uh
chair's wish of his heart that we do it
this way as you know ordinarily we do
not we have a
process whereby a subcommittee is
appointed and
that whole process takes place but as
you all know we haven't been able to
do that in the normal fashion and so
um mr chairman just so you know
representative porter has her hand up
representative porter
i can wait till you finish mr chair and
then i can i think i was
but go ahead i just wanted to remind
people and i'm sure most of us know this
anyway but
if the committee recommends future
legislation
or the committee does not recommend
future legislation
the bill can still be filed in either
case
so it doesn't prevent us saying we don't
recommend future legislation doesn't
mean
that the bill can't come back in a
different form
or the same form next term is that right
that is correct in fact uh nothing this
committee will do today will impact any
members ability to file any bill they
may
choose to file in the future
thank you so that that thank you for
giving me an opportunity to clarify that
representative
that being the case uh
let's do house bill
might as well go in order house bill
do i have a motion representative bridge
run
5 41 541
41. mr chairman i would move that house
bill 541
uh not be recommended for future
legislation
uh thank you but mr a second into that
motion representative
has moved uh that house bill a second
seconded by representative gay uh
representative
you're recognized to speak to your
motion thank you mr chairman
um i have a number of concerns with the
legislation but but
the major one really is that this bill
would take effect
when uh the states that represent a
majority of electoral votes
have enacted this agreement um in a
research
office memo done on this bill back in
january of
2019 it was pointed out there were four
538 electors and a majority would be
uh 270 and we're only at 172
um electors now falling
under this national popular vote compact
but even if we hit the 270 number
that still leaves a big hole of 268
electors who won't be following
the national popular vote so i have a
little concern with the threshold itself
personally if it was a little higher
i could probably support the bill but
simply being a majority vote
i don't and one of the arguments for
this is that currently the the
presidential campaigns are
are being conducted geographically so
that uh
candidates can target uh you know swing
states
i don't think that's really going to
change under a national popular vote
um they're then going to be simply
targeting the high population centers
and that's going to shift a lot of the
attention towards small states like new
hampshire
uh towards some of the largest cities
like like new york and pennsylvania and
california
so that they can get a better uh total
in their
national popular vote numbers so as the
bill is currently written i can't
support it
i recognize that this is the fifth time
the bill's been introduced in
in recent years and it'll be probably a
sixth time in the next session but uh
as it is presently written i can't i
can't support house bill 541 and
so that's the purpose of my motion so
anyone else who wishes to be recognized
to speak on
the present motion on house bill 541
represent pearson you are recognized
thank you pam thank you mr uh chair
um as a co-sponsor of this bill i think
it's no mystery that
that i'd i'll be voting against this
motion
uh but i just wanted to quickly address
uh
some of the reasons why and i mean this
is a big
uh discussion 270 electors
it seems like we could get in the weeds
about it but sometimes i think it's
easier to distill it
just to the core principles and you know
when when this country was founded
the big hedge against uh the big hedge
against population was the senate
that's the institutional body that was
formed uh to hedge against uh you know
the metropolitan um cities on the coast
it wasn't the presidential electors and
i think that the use of them
as this hedge is is is kind of
antithetical to what this government was
founded on
um i also think that while those other
electors
uh the the the 270 that haven't or the
the group that
didn't follow the 270 to do this popular
vote
um initiative they'd still be included
in and who selects the president by
virtue of those states population being
factored into the national popular vote
um
count so with those reasons i'll vote
against this motion
and um i recognize that it takes a lot
to get bills passed in new hampshire
state house and i hope that
um we see this again thanks
thank you representative pearson is
there anyone else who wishes to speak
on the motion of not recommended for
future legislation
representative griffin has her hand up
and just so you know representative reed
also has her hand up
uh represent representative griffin
thank you mr chair i just wanted to
follow up on representative pearson's
comments
because what it caused to come to my
mind
is that i think one could argue
that if congress and the senate which
are the bodies constitutionally
who are supposed to be the ones um
doing things on a federal level were
doing what they were supposed to be
doing
and not basically abdicating a lot of
responsibility to the white house
for many many many terms maybe the press
for national popular vote wouldn't be
so persistent thank you thank you
is there any further remarks to be made
by any members of the committee on house
bill 541 before we move
to a vote representative hayward has his
hand up
representative hayward you are
recognized
thank you mr chairman i i would uh
try and point out as we all know this
the uh checks and balances that were
written into the constitution
uh at the beginning were put there for a
reason
as uh representative pearson mentioned
the
checks and balance in the legislative
branch
are currently still in place but this
the electoral college is the check that
was put into the executive branch
so that the authorities
the principal authority of the president
being to execute
and administer the laws passed by the
congress apply
fairly across the nation as a whole
[Music]
so i uh i believe that
representative bergeron is uh
is on the right path here
thank you the clerk will call the role
the motion is
excuse me mr chairman uh representative
porter has your hand up
i beg your pardon represent porter it's
okay mr chair
um i'm i just want to explain that
okay something was said during the
testimony today that kind of hit home
about how the people in their 20s today
have had two presidential elections
where the
winner of the popular vote was not
elected president
and i know that a term ago when i was
doing the orientation for the new
hampshire legislative youth advisory
council
the bill that that group of young people
heard
in our mock committee hearing was this
bill
and they overwhelmingly supported the
concept
of getting rid of the
electoral college as we know it because
they felt that their voices
would not count so
although i see some issues in the bill
that's presented i think i'm going to
have to be voting
that we should pursue it at a later date
with another piece of legislation
thank you well of course representative
porter you know very well
that will be doing that i suspect in any
case
you're right mr chair i know that
any further discussion hearing none the
clerk will call the rule on the motion
of
not recommended for future legislation
okay representative moynihan
i'm sorry about the delay i vote in
support of the motion
representative porter i vote no
representative ward no
representative pearson
i don't know representative damaris i
will vote no
representative bergeron yes
representative sandler
is representative sandler still in
connection here she is she married
i just had my mute on i didn't take it
off in time it's uh i'm voting yes
representative hamer i vote yes
representative higgins or she's absent
representative lane
no representative martins
yes representative hozel
yes representative gay
she muted
i actually don't see her in the hearing
i don't see her anymore either
uh she must be here she's she's
reconnecting as we speak
okay why don't we pause from we'll pause
for a moment
representative gay are you in contact
representative gay
i say her name and i don't see the mute
on
either but i'm not hearing her i see no
microphone
oh she's connected oh wait a minute here
we go
looks like it's having difficulty it
does
uh madam click why don't you move on and
we'll come back to her
at the end okay representative prudhomme
o'brien
um oh yes
haywood yes
representative griffin yes
representative gay is still connecting
you're not done yet anyway
i'll go back to i'm sorry you like to be
last representative cody
uh yes
calling representative gay and see if we
can find out what's happening on her
that would be a good idea i don't think
i've encountered this particular
situation
before i was just going to offer to call
her i don't know if she's using her
computer for this
or or her phone but i'll call her right
now if you'd like
please do so um brad greenman was also
trying to call so you might
okay have a conflict yeah
thank you
she may want to connect by telephone
instead of
by computer that's fine she just has to
do that
i had to do that because i kept losing i
kept
he kept blocking out on me yep
apologies but you know these things
happen
i know can someone tell me
how to raise my hand on the telephone
star nine
why did you want to raise your hand not
technically
but in case i do
and star six is mute unmute if you want
to use that
do you know about any music capability
we might utilize for times like this pam
at all
i don't you don't want to hear me sing
either
i can sing though if you would you could
yeah
well that yes that i know
at least we know when this happens the
next time
i don't have any ideas about deal with
it other than wait
yep that's all you can do right i just
keep seeing that you know that it's
trying to connect to the audio
and never quite gets beyond that you
know
actually she seconded the motion
she did
but i'm not making assumptions no we're
not we're not going down that road
no smart move david
thank you
tempting but no
i think i convinced her with my speech
could be
it was a good one i got something
in the supreme court case about
faithless electors
yep i bet she's very frustrated
i can bet that that's a fair statement
this is going to take from us i bet
i would bet should we tell her to hang
up and
join us again well i think we already
did if she can hear us
right and i'm sure brad would suggest
that as you know that's that's often the
solution to to many connection problems
but
uh i haven't heard back from him he said
he'd call
you know a few minutes ago and i'm sure
they're
on the phone together i imagine they're
on the phone together
i think we're gonna have to get used to
this
i won't have to well no that's true
unfortunately and we are not happy about
that
no we are not well i appreciate all the
time i've had with people
good people enjoyed my time
now i'm going to stay home
that makes two of us that makes too many
of you
actually
who just said two of us me
edie see you oh i didn't know that
okay i'm not running again
okay i'm not either i miss
it though getting getting old
i'm not old yet but i'm getting oh
please
please this is not an appropriate time
for me to tell you what i think about
that argument
okay david we'll talk later i bet you
you understand exactly what i have in my
mind though
yes i do
uh it's been a pleasure it's and it's
been
a learning experience also
i don't know if i'll ever get any of my
kids to run for something like this
though
well if they're your kids they should do
it because they'll be good at it
if if heredity it has anything to do
with it at all
thank you david i think they're sick of
politics
some days i am too yes i know
oh we'll miss you kathy thank you
yeah i i might not
gone totally you're still going to hear
from me
good i would want to okay
thank you i would want to
just so you know i have heard from brad
and he said that they're
she that representative gay could hear
but could not be heard
and he sent her the public link and i
suggested maybe
phoning in instead but um they're
they're working on it there's
oh it looks like she's on yeah oh goody
great all right clerk
yes we have just taken the vote on hb
541 and you are the only person who has
not
voted and the vote is to not
recommend for future legislation how do
you vote
i voted yes you want yes
thank you hang up i guess
therefore uh mr chair that the
um gays were 11 votes and the nays are
five so the motion carries
thank you madam clerk uh i would say not
only to represent bergeron but all
subsequent people
charged with having to present a
statement to me regarding the
committee's action that i will accept
them
no later than noon on monday
and if that is that a sufficient amount
i assume that will be a sufficient
amount of time for everybody
sure and uh
we will move on to
house bill 554 and i will recognize
representative lane for a motion
thank you uh i'm going to move
that we recommend against uh future
registration
i'm sorry legislation um
do you want me to speak further or just
lay there i i will
first let's let's let's let's recognize
the motion and get a second
is there a second to the motion i did i
understand correctly
promotions not to recommend for future
legislation is that right
that's correct uh seconded by
representative hozel
representative lane you're recognized to
speak to your motion
okay i will essentially be plagiarizing
[Music]
representative moynihan's report earlier
in the year
while the verification of the machines
of the accurate
machines that count the votes is
important
we found that the terms of the bill did
not resolve
the conflicting principles that it
sought to correct we found a lot of
issues with them and i feel also that
they may be resolved in other ways
so for that reason i'm moving against
future legislation
i thank you representative lane does
anyone else wish to speak to the motion
uh representative bergeron has his hand
up representative bergeron
yes thank you mr chairman i i would also
like to point out that uh
senate bill 283 became law uh and you
may remember that that was senator
gray's bill it
contained a number of provisions but one
of those
dealt with a post-election audit of
electronic ballot counting devices
one of the provisions is that the
secretary of state shall complete the
study by november 1st
2020. i think we're we're very close to
uh having that report due
um to us and and i i think it bears uh
waiting for that report and so i will
also be supporting the
the motion here to uh not recommend
future
legislation on this particular bill
thank you representative bergeron any
further discussion
the motion is not to recommend future
legislation
on house bill 554 the clerk will call
the roll
representative moynihan
um i vote yes on the motion to not
representative porter i vote no
on the motion to not i'm a sponsor of
the bill
representative ward yes
representative pearson yes
representative damaris i will vote no
as also a sponsor on the bill
representative bergeron
yes representative sandler
yes representative
hamer i vote yes
representative representative lane
yes representative
martens yes
representative hozel yes
representative day yes
representative prudhomme o'brien yes
representative haywood yes
representative griffin yes
representative cody yes
thank you um the yeas are 14
the nays are two
the motion i would reiterate that the
statement should be
to me by monday um
we will move on to house bill 728
uh represent porter i believe you have a
motion
yes mr chair i would like to move that
we recommend for
[Music]
further legislation
representative porter has moved
recommended for future legislation on
house bill 728
is there a second
can i speak to my motion mr chair yes i
was about to recognize you to do just
that representative and you are hereby
thank you representative mr chair um
rank choice voting is getting more and
more popular with the population as
at large i think it's worth looking
into i would highly recommend that the
people who
file this bill again next term
do increase the amount of education
that they do to help people understand
the process
because to be honest with me with you
what i read to prepare for this
meeting today did not make it as clear
to me as it should have
um i think they also need to make some
provision
to help the local
election officials understand the
process
and allay their fears but i think it's
worth looking into
i think it might take a while but i
think we should be pursuing this idea
thank you
thank you representative porter is there
any further discussion
on house bill 728 the motion is to
recommend for future legislation
we've got hands from representatives
pearson bergeron and pruden o'brien uh
represent pearson you're recognized
thank you mr chair i just wanted to be
specific about
what i'm trying to signify with this
vote i
i'm taking this vote because i think the
state house should take on for
further or future legislation around
this issue of ranked choice voting
i don't know right actually i do know i
don't think the bill that we see before
us today
is that legislation was that hb 728
i think there are significant questions
about um the plurality issue
as it pertains to new hampshire's
constitution and even if you said we
could do it on a presidential level
um and ignore state races i really don't
think
our our poll workers are going to be
running two different kinds of elections
on any given year
i don't think that's right to ask for
them and that's a nice segue into part
two
my comments about this is an idea which
is that
we need to get local officials behind it
i mean
by this vote you're getting a green
light from at least some members on the
house election law
committee that this is a good idea to go
forward with
um but i want to be specific that the
bill we see today
doesn't include that language um and
that's why we're doing this vote in the
first place otherwise
we we would be going forward with policy
with this
as a policy initiative so i think
there's a lot of work to be done with
local officials too
how are we going to be doing recounts is
this easily done
i mean the ballot machines we have right
now don't work with it so we need to be
sure that the ballot machines we buy do
if that's where we're going to go if
that's the direction we decide to go
so i just wanted to be clear about what
this vote signifies and um
again i do look forward to seeing what
this bill is going to become
uh next term and and maybe the term
after we'll see how it goes
thanks thank you represent pearson
uh let me see represent bergeron you're
recognized
thank you mr chairman i'll be voting
against the motion
uh for several reasons first of all
there's no fiscal
note on the legislation although
maine's experience can probably give us
a good idea what that cost will be
prior to the first use of rank choice
voting a memo issued by the
maine secretary of state projected a
cost of eighty thousand dollars per
election
um following that election indicated
that the actual cost was
102 653
so if we're looking at two or three
elections a year
um then certainly you know just multiply
that number by that
number of elections the second thing is
i want to address the issue of machines
um it is true the secretary of state is
exploring the certification
of new voting machines that
certification will have to be done by
the ballot law commission
however the state does not pay for these
machines it's the local cities and towns
that have to pay for them
and so i would assume that once these
machines new machines are certified
the state will allow the ones that are
in current use to continue being used
until such time as the towns and cities
find the money to buy new machines
so there is a cost here that's unlike
the experience in maine
where it's my understanding that the
secretary of state's office
paid for the machines so that's a
concern
i also would like to echo representative
pearson's comments
that i have concerns about the
consistency that
applicated the consistent application of
rank choice voting
it will be used for some races perhaps
in state and federal elections but not
in local elections
and there's going to be a constant
re-education of voters going
on by our city and town officials trying
to get them to understand
which type of accounting is going to be
used at the polling places
there's also the question of the
definition of plurality
our state constitution requires that
among others the
governor the executive council the
senators be elected by a plurality of
the vote
and this the the term plurality is not a
policeman's
word by that i mean it doesn't have
multiple meanings uh
the meaning of the word goes back to the
13th or 14th century and it simply means
a plurality occurs when the votes
received by a candidate are greater than
those received
by any opponent but can be less than the
majority of the total vote and that
comes from
the texas secretary of state's glossary
of terms
so i have concerns about the
constitutional applications of some
provisions of this law
the bill redefines plurality by saying
a certain minimum percentage of votes is
needed to achieve a plurality
um well you know you could say that a
duck is a
a mammal with long legs and big lip
smout and a humpback and lives in the
desert
but that doesn't mean that a camel is a
duck so it's
getting a little off track there but
just applying a new definition to a term
that has had the same meaning for
centuries
i don't think would pass legal muster so
those are some of the reasons i'll be
voting against this bill
thank you representative representative
o'brien
uh i'm voting against this as well i the
complexity of it
uh is a as a large reason i
had the opportunity to attend a large
gathering in maine
i brought this issue up no one in the
room
was happy with ranked choice voting and
it
started it seemed to start quite an
argument but
not really because everyone was in
agreement that it was too complex and
they didn't like it
yeah i don't like the courier idea we
have to get our
elections done on the same day in new
hampshire
and having couriers taking
part things uh around the state
to then be uh processed elsewhere
that that's scary to me when everything
that every other state election law that
we have
it focuses on transparency and
understandability
of the people that are there at the
polling place to observe
everything going on so i will be voting
you know on this one thank you
representative o'brien
so anyone else who wishes to speak to
the motion which is that
the bill be approved for future
legislation
if not um i have something to say i will
be voting
against the motion but i will be doing
so
as previous speakers have said because i
do not think that the bill
has written and before us is ready for
prime
time for constitutional and other
reasons that does not mean that i'm
taking a position
that any and all future versions of
and suggestions about ranked choice
voting will necessarily
meet with my disapproval i i just feel
constrained
that we are we don't have the
flexibility we might
otherwise have to amend and i
think um therefore if i were going to
vote on it
as it's before me i think i have to vote
no it
it no sense is a is a
discouragement to the sponsor or anyone
else who wants to explore
other avenues
and thank you that being the case
madam clerk you may call the role the
motion is approved for further
future legislation okay
representative moynihan i vote yes
on the recommendation for future
legislation
representative porter
i vote yes representative ward
no representative pearson
yes representative damaris i vote yes
representative bergeron
didn't hear you representative bergeron
no thank you
representative sandler
her your microphone is off yeah
i believe she's working to find her the
unmute
space bar is the hotkey to unmute real
quick
representative stanley call in some
technical support here but uh i'm voting
yes
representative hamer i vote no
representative lane yes
representative martens
yes representative hozel
no representative gay
no representative prudhomme o'brien
no representative haywood
oh
representative griffin no
and representative cody no
okay the vote is um yay
seven nays nine
all right the motion promotion fails
motion fails do i have
a further motion represent bergeron
who care to make a further motion i will
i would move that uh house bill 728
not be recommended for future
legislation representative bergeron has
moved not recommended
is there a second okay also second
thank you
represent bergeron you're recognized to
speak if you care to do so
uh i will pass in the interest of time i
think all my comments have already been
recorded any further uh any
further comments i don't have to write a
report then do i
well i'd be happy to hurt you
because i'm smart aren't i mr chair
there's never been any question about
that porter
um very well the motion is not
recommended for future legislation
uh any further comments going
going twice uh the clerk will call the
roll
was there a second to that
i believe actually there were like three
but
can we pick one yeah no
i get to pick one
and who is that so i can make a note
please that would be representative
let's just keep our paperwork up
i am fully in favor of that okay
thank you
so the motion then is to not recommend
future legislation
okay so representative moynihan
no
representative porter no
representative ward yes
representative pearson no
representative damaris no representative
bergeron
yes representative sandler
um i vote no
representative hammer yes
representative lane
no
representative martens
no representative hozel
yes representative gay
yes representative prudhomme o'brien
yes
representative haywood yes
representative griffin yes
representative cody yes
thank you um we have nine yays to seven
nine yays to seven nays so the motion
carries
thank you madam clark um we will now
move on to
whatever my phone tells me is on the
next on the list
and i'm in the wrong window
11.91
yes and uh representative pearson i
believe you have
a motion
just a second time yep
can i mute myself no i think i'm my
motion
is to recommend for future legislation
am i saying that correctly you are you
are representing pearson has moved to
recommend for future legislation is
there a second
i'll second that second
representative porter
pearson you're recognized to speak to
your motion
thank you mr chair right because i'm
still unmuted um
no so this is uh this bill uh it
goes on to specify what specific things
um
uh wouldn't be allowed as campaign
expenditures
it's not an exhaustive list but it does
again it has
it adds specificity to what you wouldn't
be allowed to use
uh your campaign donation um
the reason i'm moving that that this you
know should be uh
acted on with further legislation it's
because i think
uh we had testimony that indicated that
this was a problem for some reps eg had
wasn't cleared not it was enforceable
and that this might have helped add some
specificity to it to overuse that work
um the point is is it
makes our campaign laws a little bit
more robust and i'm in favor of that
i think future legislatures should take
that on thanks
thank you is any further discussion on
the motion to recommend
house bill 1191 for future legislation
hearing none the clerk will call the
rule
as soon as i find my roll call sheet
that's fine
okay now i just lost the one underneath
it said who's absent but
you'll catch me anyway uh
representative moynihan i vote yes on
the recommendation
representative porter yes
representative ward yes representative
pearson
yes representative damaris yes
representative bergeron yes
is absent representative lane yes
representative martins yes
representative hosel no
representative gay
all right sorry yes
representative uh lang is
absent i believe yeah absent
representative prudhomme o'brien
[Music]
yes
representative haywood no
representative uh i think merlin now
he's absent
oh well i'll get it while we're talking
um
representative griffin no
okay the vote is uh 12 days
did i miss someone just making sure
because i don't have the list
just our chair oh representative
cody i am sorry ah yes
uh the answer is yes thank you
the total is 13 yays and three
i'm hearing background noise from
somewhere
it can watch the legislative action
oh it's represent moynihan is that your
lovely wife in the background there
i just mutable that was that was my son
oh okay
uh we will move on to house bill 1390
and i will recognize representative
bergeron for a motion
i would move that house bill 1390
not be recommended for future
legislation represent bergeron has moved
not recommended on house bill
1390 is there a second
i'll second that motion holder
to speak to your motion thank you mr
chairman
um just like a similar bill
discussed earlier this afternoon uh
senate bill 283
was uh um passed by the house and senate
and signed into law by the governor it
requires that the secretary of state
provide a report or a plan on how to
conduct uh
verification on our electronic voting
devices and i
believe we should wait for that and see
what uh the secretary of state is
proposing
i also have a a real problem with the
concept that
25 voters in the district can
effectively slow down the vote count uh
on an election just by saying that we
want
a hand count done on one of the races um
at the end of the night and i just can't
imagine what that would mean if someone
did that for the upcoming presidential
election
how late our poll workers would be uh at
the polls
we buy the uh electronic voting devices
to speed up the process
and this would slow it down tremendously
i just uh can't support
uh the concept that's being proposed by
this bill
thank you representative bergeron any
further discussion on the motion not
recommending
house bill 1390
hearing none the clerk will call the
role
when i picked up the piles i had
everything so organized
i just didn't know that
that okay i will use this one
and this will do it 13.90 okay
um representative moynihan
i vote yes on the recommendation
representative porter yes
representative ward yes
representative pearson yes
representative damaris i will vote
nay uh representative bergeron
yes representative sandler
yes representative hamer
yes representative higgins
oh she's not here representative uh lane
yes representative martens
yes representative
yes representative gay
yes representative prudhomme o'brien
yes representative haywood
yes representative griffin
yes the vote is
uh representative cody the
vote is yes okay the vote is 15 to 1.
the motion carries thank you
you will move on therefore to house bill
and i will recognize representative
bergeron for a motion
uh i would move that uh house bill 1457
not be recommended for future
legislation represent bergeron has moved
that house bill 1457
not be recommended for future
legislation is there a second
second seconded by i think
representative ward
yep
uh represent bergeron you're recognized
to speak to your motion
uh thank you mr chairman um well i think
the the intent of this legislation is
good
um some of the provisions make the
process
of working with the nursing homes and
other assisted
living facilities somewhat onerous among
them for example
is the requirement that a public notice
be provided 30 days prior to the date of
any visit
i know from from my own experience that
it's not unusual
for new residents in a nursing home to
ask maybe
days or or a week before an election if
someone might come out to get them
registered to vote
at their new residence there's also the
the dynamics of trying to get
supervisors of the checklists and town
clerks
uh being able to meet at the same time
and then finally the definition of how
many
types of facilities this affects is
pretty broad
um nashua has about seven nursing homes
in its and assisted living facilities uh
in its boundaries
but there are about 30 homes that would
fall within the
the definitions provided by this
legislation so
um well i think it would be a great idea
to develop some kind of best practices
or standards
ask the secretary of state to to share
that with the city and town clerks
i i just don't think it's appropriate to
incorporate it into our statutes
as as written in this legislation at
this time
thank you representative bergeron is
there any further discussion on the
motion
not to recommend house bill 1457
there are two hands not mr chairman
representatives ward and prudhomme
o'brien
representative award is recognized
i just wanted to agree with what the
previous comments
were and to say that it's obviously a
very well-intentioned bill
that seems impractical in its current
form
uh thank you representative ward
representative o'brien
i still think it's a valid bill uh
and the idea is good 23 states
require this sort of thing if the
hang up is about definitions of kind of
homes
and that is something that can be worked
on
and i know that administrators of
nursing homes
did tell me that they would be pleased
to have
this sort of situation because then they
would be certain that they were in
they were acting in accordance to all
state laws
and it would make them more comfortable
so not only them
but that residents would be more
comfortable knowing that everything was
done correctly
we do pay our clerks and uh supervisors
of the checklist
so i i feel like if this is a job that
people are being paid to do
then uh this could fall under it so i do
strongly believe that uh visiting
nursing homes in
homes of disabled adults is still a very
valid thing
for helping them to
access that process thank you thank you
and that are two more hands up mr
chairman representatives holzel
and gay representative hosel you are
recognized
thank you mr chairman although i'm a
co-sponsor of this bill i do think it
has
many many things in it that concern
me i know that most town clerks
if they were asked to go to a nursing
home
or one of these facilities
they would show um i think this
would be too restrictive
and and it will cost money
so i i'm going to go with not
recommended
i think that if anyone wishes to put
another
uh bill in they're welcome to do that
thank you representative um
pam i forgot who the other hand up was
representative gay
representative gay how could i forget
you you're recognized
thank you mr chair and maybe maybe that
was a freudian
slip i doubt it i
i um i uh support
what a representative holtzel just said
it's uh got a good intent
i think it can be worked out so that
it's
offers a supportive service to
these many kinds of homes
but it needs to be a new bill needs to
be written
so i will say that i support the current
the current uh motion but i'm hoping
that in the future
we can do a new bill and make it so that
it's
advisory and offers help upon request
but not obligatory
uh thank you representative gay i see no
other hands and
i'm going to say just briefly i agree
with the comments of
all the people who spoke affirmatively
and i would
suggest that the sponsor
persevere because this is not this is
something that
again you're caught between the issue of
how the bill is written versus the
concept and
i think everyone is in favor of the
concept but
a little leery of the situation and in
addition i'm not sure how
enactment of this bill as it currently
is
would work in our current nursing home
situation
since we seem to have some significant
covert
issues with with nursing homes that were
obviously not
to anyone much less the sponsor at the
time
um this particular version was filed so
so yes i will i'll reluctantly
vote for this motion but i would urge
the sponsor to persevere
thank you
any further discussion the motion is not
to recommend
house bill 14
hearing the clerk we'll call the roll
okay
representative moynihan i vote yes
representative porter yes representative
ward
yes representative pearson
yes representative damaris yes
representative bergeron yes
representative sandler
vote yes representative hamer
i vote yes representative
lane yes representative martens
yes representative
yes representative day
yes representative o'brien
oh
representative haywood
griffin yes
representative cody yes
hello
oh prudhomme o'brien i'm sorry
representative
o'brien i'm sorry
i thought i had registered that was
so did i miss someone representative
griffin
no you i said representative griffin
right oh is there anyone who was whose
name was not
called i thought i had everybody but i
thought i heard somebody say something
that
they were missing well what's the matter
what's the state of the vote
okay the state of the vote is 15 yays
and one nay
i think that checks out
are there six can you just check that
that's 16 that's what we've had on all
the other ones i think we may have heard
someone speaking to someone else
yeah i think we just heard somebody make
a noise and i that's why i
thought i thought maybe i was missing
someone but we have 16 votes
yeah that being the case um
we will move forward to house bill 1668
which for the information of those of
you
who may not be following along is the
last bill which i
suspect some of our attendees are
looking at with great relief
i would recognize representative pearson
who i believe has a motion
as correct i'm going to recommend this
inexpedient for
future legislation representative
pearson
has moved not recommended for future
legislation is there a
second target seconded by representative
ward i believe
representative pearson you are
recognized to speak to your motion
thank you mr chair i'll be real quick i
you know i think that
especially right now with the kobit 19
situation early voting is something that
you know
the committee should be looking at it's
uh this was
gonna pertain to early voting only as it
regards to uh
disabled persons we saw some significant
hurdles with how this would work and
we're not sure that the pilot program
with disabled people is the
right way to go but um but yeah
nevertheless i
i still stand by the motion that it's uh
not expedient for future legislation
thank you representative pearson to say
for the discussion on the motion
not to recommend for future legislation
house bill 1668
to chairman yes representative bergeron
uh if i may i have just a very brief
comment
sure uh i supported this going to
interim study for
one reason only
one of the speakers who presented on
behalf of the granite state independent
living foundation
mentioned an interest in trying to have
the accessible
voting tablets available at the city or
town clerk's office
prior to an election so they could use
the same device
in town hall if they weren't going to
the polls as they would if they did go
to the polls
i think that's something that can be
pursued outside of legislation
and uh i just wanted the committee
members to know that i'll have a
discussion with the secretary of state's
office to see how practical it would be
um logistically to try and
address that uh interest among the
disabled community uh but other than
that i agree with
representative pearson's comments and
that will support the motion
thank you representative bergeron um i
would suggest that maybe
you might get together with
representative pearson when he writes a
statement then see if some
uh positive nod might be made in that
direction
in the actual statement itself thank you
um that being the case is there any
further discussion on the motion
uh not to recommend house bill 1668
hearing none the clerk will call the
roll
okay representative moynihan yes
representative porter yes representative
ward
yes representative pearson
yes representative damaris yes
representative bergeron yes
representative sandler
yes representative hamer
yes
representative lane yes representative
martens
yes representative hosel
yes
yes okay i heard you i'm sorry
representative gay
yes representative
tom o'brien yes
representative oh and no wait a minute
no no heywood
yes
okay representative griffin
yes representative cody
yes the vote is 16 to zero
the motion thank you very much uh that
having been concluded i believe we are
at the end of our business
um i would like to first of all i would
like to thank pam
for her stalwart service as the in this
and all
other matters
yay pam this is not obviously in her job
description and you saw how well she
handled it
uh and uh so you know we are thankful
as we always are to pam who is blushing
uh
and i also want to say that it's it's
been a great privilege to be your chair
for
the uh past two years and uh those of
you who are unfortunately leaving us
i have great regrets about that i wish i
would have been able to talk some of you
out of it but i'm quite sure you'll be
very
happy in front of one way or the other
if we have to go back to concord and
it's
there's nine feet of snow on the ground
and i'd just like to say thank you to
each and every one of you
it's been a great privilege thank you
yay david okay
but you can't see me blushing
fortunately uh the chair will entertain
a motion to adjourn so moved
is there a second
thank you very much thank you goodbye
everybody
and see you see you at unhahaha
i can't get out of the way